par en service à partir ou une entrevue
avec ses six maires nous allons lui
poser quelques questions parce qu'elle a
vraiment vous générosité a tenté de
venir à cette première berlinoise adepte
première mondiale à celui des adm et ma
question du genre de nous
bonjour à tous
merci que je viens
en dix mois
c'est dans mon année ici d'abord parce
que c'est une initiative
et pour marquer donc on remarque 2010
l'année des frappes ont du mal à
soutenir à son courage et à ce domaine
en france principalement quand elles ont
des initiatives se voir ma vie privée
générant aux antilles
pour tout de suite quant à moi j'ai tué
6 février
j'avais ensuite c'est une piètre jeu
gimbert h 20 jeu j'avais jadis par et
d'un raison mon troisième présentement
c'est qu'on parle du thé
au regard de toutes ces choses qu'on a
besoin pour les femmes associées
je sois artistique wawatie mais merci
beaucoup et je profite pour commerçants
parce que la transition est toute
trouvée
la question que je me prépare
c'est vraiment cette première édition
des statuts dès cet hiver
alors qu'est ce que c'était et l'europe
j'ai sur ma main je veux
parce que ça avait bien dit aujourd'hui
avoir un peu ce que chacun pense être le
seul mot j'étais justement la victime
elle revendiqué mais l'évolution du site
alizés boorman de shit man show européen
ce parti mais j'ai manqué deux ans par
exemple ici l'article de nuisance je
pense verizon programme aura des rituels
des maisons au slam est bon
je pense que ça pose à chaque moment
important
demain nous avons été bougés pour maman
je suis sûr que chaque personne de
l'assistance que j'ai abandonné par
s'appelle chose
aura-t-il servi comportement dans la
société savante et jugé qui font tourner
a du mal à s'épanouir
mais moi j'étais quand on demande à
mithra on prend sa place dans la société
il faut d'abord vous étreint et rappelle
qu'ils sont par les pouvoirs en place
sinon pour le n'hésite pas ne dit rien
de laisser place au parlement et dieu
sait pendant combien de jours je vais
revermont
son suivante y mange ici mais c'est
tellement active en ce que vous êtes en
train de tout type
disons de cicatrices de restauration de
soi gens parlaient alors parce
qu'effectivement le 10 décembre dernier
et l arbitraire prévu dans la nuit sa
respiration fait
le fédérer sacrés qui tombait à pic avec
le terme de cet événement
venez au medef
mourir
et la question pourquoi j'avais envie de
composer s'il est vrai que je vous vois
beaucoup et vous avez une autre partie
béninoise l'apprécier
exalead et ça va je suis sûr public avec
moi en me les envoie c'est vrai qu'on
avait déjà en génie des mérigots là je
sens vraiment c'est vrai qu'on avait et
la peau est fine semaine qu'est ce que
c'est mais en se lançant dans cette
industrie musicale avait en il est de
laisser comme les pâtes
quelle est cette différence quelle est
cette valeur ajoutée peut s'estimer
avait envie de porter avec elle vous
faire rayonner sur la scène mondiale
jusqu'à quel âge d obésité pendant que
je dire
malgré tout je vais être une chanteuse
hesdinois et je vais me diras tu es là
c'est vrai qu'on a mangé c'est
maintenant on avait d'un gymnase et
c'est un bonheur immense aux données
comparées que ces deux grandes dames de
la société et vous dire peut chanter
c'est d'abord en vip à ce point est
malheureusement tendance aussi offert
mémoire des enfants à l'état vend à
travers leurs patients quand vous allez
vous étudiez ça se voie du progrès vous
laisser vous étiez de côté ou bien
occupé pour y chanter
voulait-on ce qu ils n auront écrivait
on se dit c'est roger la 1re de novotel
actuelle qui est là mais quand on est
chantée ou d'y marquer ou danseuses ont
tous ses dérivés
dumange du reste du monde et zares on
voit cela me raisonne votes en avance et
du patient est abandonnée je me suis dit
et si je vous avais dit choqué avance
qui défend des causes internes aux
défendre des causes qui concerne la spa
qui concerne l'enfant qui fait parler de
son pays à l'extérieur c'est dans
d'autres pays nous avons des stades et
de cet artiste à qui à travers leur
argent quelque chose pour que leur vie
by laurent j
je peux aussi je pense le faire je
remercie mes parents d'avoir donné la
motorisation la permission de le faire
et si mon père m'avait dit non je serais
pas là aujourd'hui
mon père m'a dit oui tu es tu dis moi je
veux juste des résultats scolaires
situés dans une fosse polaire
tu peux parler avec la nation et donc
j'ai ri quand ils vont à ce mot j'ai
mise
continuer ma nation mais c'est dire que
à travers la musique
j'aimerais qu'on comprenne que nos
patients sont également invités qui
apportent une valeur ajoutée à votre
pays pour un artiste sont jouées aux
antilles ce fait la promotion
on se demande qui vient d'acquérir saab
a même eu beaucoup plus vite que les
politiques et j'aimerais qu'on comprenne
cela dans ce pays aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup d'artistes j'aimerais comme on
gagne cela et moi c'est une fierté quand
tu parles pas pour jeudi
un oubli du pays angélique kidjo angeli
fidjien du bénin le bénin ou avant
d'occuper donc forcément à travers la
musique on apporte quelque chose à son
pays et donc à travers cette même
musique on passe des messages
on défend des causes en apportant plus
qu'un associé à ces personnes qui vous
écoute on demande y est aussi un exemple
unique aux ados personnes pour d'autres
personnes qui nous écoutent qu'ils
abondent
qui nous dit que j'étais problème moi
aussi j'ai envie de faire telle chose
qui se valent qu'on est telle situation
on reçoit beaucoup de visages d'une box
les manches lundi un peu aujourd'hui
au départ c'était assez compliqué le roi
la société d'aller vraiment de bons
éléments mais aujourd'hui j'ai en tout
cas en partie dépendre totalement parce
qu'elle ne sait si c'est d'entraînement
partie en partie parce que chanteuse
dans une société comme le méthane
d'objets coupe davis et la dépravation
bourgi ondes il est copain avec marie
voit le roi n'a pas d'enfant voilà
pourquoi si est-ce que l'existence ou la
réussite ou les gangs de rue si le
succès dans une société c'est le mariage
c'est un enfant il faudrait pouvoir se
réaliser soi même d'abord il faudrait
que même si on a des enfants compris ce
soit même en tant qu'être humain se
sentir épanouie pour pouvoir mieux
d'ailleurs mieux s'occuper de ses
enfants
il ya des personnes qui ont des enfants
qui sont avec cet endroit et je ne sont
pas dûment nuit ya eu même pas fonction
de ces marouane ya des personnes qui
sont dans tous les mariages mais en
prison ils sont dans un mariage parce
que aux yeux de la société il faut se
marier les fonds des grands comptes mais
qui sont par le web et vous allez
rencontrer d'autres vins qui sont saisis
et qui son père part peut-être y en a
qui sont beaucoup plus heureuse séquence
de deux personnages et moi j'ai dit
aujourd'hui j'ai déployé cette chance
d'évoluer sous le poids d'un mec j'ai
une relation personnelle privée
je n'ai pas eu cette chance d'avoir des
enfants mais aujourd'hui ce sont les
femmes qui transforme en un an le matin
et qu'on veut
en gros tout ce qu'on veut j'ai eu les
dix ans des parents m'ont donné une
éducation
j'apprends le bal à relever tous les
défis dans métier à aller de l'avant
charon ami lui trois mêmes d'abord quand
je me regarde dans les joueurs qui
touchent la vie à ma question et à ne
pas revivre avec le regard des autres
anne marie thus que parce que les on
veut que je sois encore ce qui je voyais
corps cela non on doit apprendre la
triple ambition ne le sont pas pourquoi
robert blake je suis vraiment ravi
d'être à la société non et chacun dans
sa différence
ap une richesse à apporter à cette
société là du coup moi je pense que tout
a dégénéré en parties aujourd'hui toutes
les attaques doucement me dire je suis
je suis prêt je suis ville amazon et par
moderne je suis prêt dans la tête je
fais mon job comme je dois le faire
j'apprends la rive de l'avant et si la
vie moi des opportunités jeu
écrans géants soir ouah ce soir j'avais
la chair de poule lorsque j'ai
effectivement tout ce que vous avez
tissé ces gens chantant des
établissements dans le public parce que
je pense que toutes les familles ont
envie effectivement de se réaliser à
rentrer dans leur vie pour raconter le
faire elle vais vous raconter le film
concert à la société se retrouve face en
fait à ce regard ce regard est séparé
vous avez tellement de france et faire
ce que je voulais jongler demandé à la
suite je voudrais pas de ça a été très
déçu ce soir je me suis dit voilà le
message puissant le message percutant le
bessin espérant de cette journée c'est
vraiment essayé de se révéler tel qu'on
est des professionnels courageux et bien
entendu que prendre le portefeuille reer
soirée parce que j'en ai pas complétion
les parents tier 1 ne vienne à manquer à
la société qui nous entoure et
j'aimerais vraiment
demandez à ce public qui avait été là
aujourd'hui te me revois à bloquer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
première tétée est ce que à terme ou
même je suis vraiment reconnaissante et
je pense que roland du comité
d'organisation de toutes les amazones il
s'y présentait les celui bienveillant
on vous présente vraiment en
remerciement les bus les plus profonds
et 13 jours et ne faisait pour lancer
droit des ans cet événement
merci d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]